ives sure the whitehouse
prescor we don't have to bleat you
descent therapy center stimulant a
new questions and socially and there's
the original question that a spider pro
score en is i'm just that many times
vanderpoorten renske thumping
en cel gibson an answer and quickly
wrist and as nice as the next reporter
sherry cities question etcetera etcetera
and so die get something der applications
en answer and earlier i played for you i
realy would more and more bad french
medical records bbc for his former
doctor help us team and in order finite
living  historical monuments press
briefing axel i watch time of the entire
fang
en oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh this watching the
briefing yesterday
de shea st legion answer  questions and
often straight alliance in order to
avoid answering questions regarding
apple i simples for the upset is
a matter that was hope in whitby and
wit ac  working hard weekends
backstories
frank castle on history of his dogs
guiltypeople who realizes rayon
legal2people
to post reviews of reviews the
innocent people branch just tell the truth
last week i learn a donald trumps
personal or michael cohen how the queen
of so the abs question  for the white
house for transfer heels those centers
who speaks for the white house is so
krans guiding principle that clothes lift
instead kilt of flyer michael common
ground the white house crash course vs
caribbean else the 16th
listen to her and der about ilias and annie
janssen  and save healthy life window
in question of me so of ask you
something
labor updates post wk in report
of the plots charlie michael kelly and
brokerage man
solid public to sir this is the people
running since you become as loose
casserole no trace of the president
and  with this also gone in September 2017
the house and church ilic
the matrix and coats city view in is in
waikiki de witt  e mallows
high tea is also buy you might already
gone fishing speak on behalf of michael
cohen a different freeshipping
so far and there ipad speak on behalf of
michael come the question was what is the
president inc
what is the president believe this donald
trump stand  -by is comment this is a
straight line therapy center boar has
the question ben what is michael can
build a tank rapper denchik the salon
the whitehouse press secretary and don't
speak for the personal ooijer en arguably
formal per trip under
personalize on donald  trump single
comment
josh replace the nuns here we the
symbolism symphony josie pye the soup
shirt sarah
so your sister like will smith is an
actor
so you can dance league are us speak
on the ragged with boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy  oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy in arnhem went to
a and sir nl-nl
like this' doortjes spicy i haven't
cramp in my house and that kind of
k  westie on it took a tube and sang the
issue
another example charlie's enthusiastic
about whether the white house leaked
the support from other questions by the
way since so press conference
so press briefing be found at the idea
turns here's there is and sir
chu that tassel
in everything on the for the person to
talk to you share by those paws
prieshof
performers des tentes person may for the
day after tomorrow think so my love by bon siman
once again a calm and an intriguing
discussion thread
by for every president machine dirt
or all those small  things nuts and the
lids do you visit the president
consider we many three minutes the
president personal car lease i a
speaker with is something you circular
semantic in my shadow line housewife
secretaire meaning that she is out there
you explain the people
what trump en  gis oval office heaven help
na die trump is part of the oval office
c6 wel de white house and she says
images question is debates president
na d  e but the white house so why can
actually intro that the issue isabel
de president sections white in the context
office administration the oval office
and the white house
poverty argue that this is more discreet
mocking sean spicer with rough trunk on
transfer spreadsheet editor inn you  know
who is that journal be coming shameless
attempts at maintaining a policy at
school okay glass rather than
transparency sean spicer was a clown
comical lawyer viewers naso preseli the
camping too simple op cure and now give
information and to some degree via and
allies
ear pain de les  so grace full of a
policy of trolls nice transparency
that we see from sir harry centers of
course combined and sprinkle this it was
sean spicer header sound bites osv now
sorry musical legally holten lions well
exact career advice different weather
bloopers us the cold us watch friday
blooper reel  and skating on which
to keep another of the gravity rather
than just come eagleeyes the color lisan
spice  r the indirect redemption this is
never the fans op spicer it's just
actress summer fair heels bis else de
her behavior is ie van moore so casting
and on that sean spicer and this is a
business of the white house crash course
you just not allow for the move on  which
are real answer garden suggesting is
for here the
probably won't you wish to some fear of
losing access and getting the white
house with kate people who insist on a
nora leftist hobbies else team one
really would be pro free speech words
to know what  health claims that's it
spicy
so so casting item you know how is there
was a wild standing and entire therapy
cendris press briefing and me personally
pushing 19 manchester reviews
oh yeah and of course unexpected was
that too that's hopefully the last beecher
ingram sir  run the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to page free run dot
com slash steven task my show you can
make up pledge detergent as one dollar
pe  r month and every dollar helps to
support word and bridging particularly
in light of the youtube app bodyguard
witches within
really bad